I'm actually excited to show you the
Russian snacks because just thinking
about the snacks that I'm gonna give you
today I'm getting excited like I'm
thinking about my childhood I'm feeling
that uh Team USA snacks are going to win
solely because they've been handcrafted
and pumped full of chemicals to make
them the perfect level of desirability
whereas Russians are like good malt
vinegar nor a book there's just gonna be
natural you're gonna feel salt you can
feel sugar I always had the best snacks
on the playground you guys trade snacks
on playgrounds in American elementary
schools everyone's like I'll give you a
pudding cup for your lunchable we had
like cigarette trades on our playground
like people were like trained in like
bottles of liquor on our players all
right snack number one we have the
pop-tart it is awesome because it can
count as a snack and a breakfast I have
Fanny key it's basically like a pop-tart
except better it's got like a beautiful
decoration it's like gingerbread flavor
and then it's got filling I'm sorry this
could literally count as a weapon yeah
so usually you would share that with
teeth
[Music]
hello that's awfully pretty good
melt-in-your-mouth not something like
that like that takes a while to shoot
yeah let's let's just show the
difference in like bread and jam ratio
and she this filling tastes like more
natural I'm gonna have to go with this
just because I think the feeling is like
delicious I'm so excited with this the
next snack we have the delicacy Hot
Pockets which could either be a
delicious pocket of pizza or an atomic
bomb of pain
here we have beta hope it's with meat
and onions chopped up together
it's sort of baked in this like whole
song that's Russian style that's pretty
good it just tastes like them is it
chicken yeah just tastes like chicken
and some bread Russia just way too much
bread that's not logical look at look at
all that stuffing that's how much
filling is in there the rest of this is
bread and I feel good I like our food
beep friggin hurricane what do you got
Tatanka people love this you go to the
baño which is like a spa and you have a
beer and you eat this dried fish and
it's honestly I'm gonna warn you it's
smells the smell I'm just gonna like
don't be rude to my culture wow it
smells
I smell in here you're ruining my beef
jerky experience you have to eat sort of
like the top like there's a bone here so
you sorta keep children could not eat
snacks with bones in them Russia see in
America we aren't even allowed to have
Kinder Surprise eggs they're worried
that American children will swallow the
toys inside a Kinder Surprise eggs I
can't
you gotta peel it and then you sort of
have a like that is it like string
cheese but string fish no serious that
stuff is great you have to mean to move
for that type of stuff I was drunk I
would be pissed that I was getting bones
of my teeth and I had to work for this
if I was stoned I would get frustrated
trying to peel it I would give up there
is no practical application for this
snack in my life a sidewalk is like
a little it's like a cold cheese cake
covered in chocolate it's amazing we
have the all-american can withstand the
apocalypse snack this is supposed to be
like frozen yeah a little bit
oh yeah okay little good oh no it's so
good but my fingers just smell like fish
my throat like burns from this Twinkie
that's not normal the Twinkie I could
have a bite of it it's really heavy for
me
this I could just kill like three of
them socratic you dried bread man
it's like croutons with flavor but we
got pretzels you know what tastes like
dried bread with salt yeah exactly
it's garlicky its herbaceous its crunchy
and oily I stand either good right
mm-hmm
oh you still love them and there's all
kinds of flavors ten out of ten would
definitely pick these over pretzels I
think I choose a long croutons over the
precipice Cheetos which are dried will
break in their base will you say that
boo bleakie it's your saying boo licky
this tastes like if you took those old
graham crackers that you have in the
back of the cabinet for like three years
that you forgot about that left you left
open and then you took them and you
ground them up then you put some water
and then you made these little circle
things and then baked them
that's actually how they make them it's
not too sweet I don't know it's too much
too much cheese how do your fingers look
that is the cheeto signature YUM these
are amazing I would lick my fingers for
these what a meal I'd this is like jello
with sugar and it tastes like lemon and
it's amazing and you have it with tea
you dip it in tea and it gets all soft
and all the sugar gets in the dirty and
then it like melts in your mouth and
it's beautiful and it's amazing it's so
delicious
Oreos it is a chocolate cream cookie I
can't say anything the Oreos are great I
mean it's even better if you just dip it
in some milk
mmm it tastes like a lemon air freshener
not good I'm not really a big lemon fan
but I like whatever this is they're both
delicious what are these called again
what a meal on money lab we got Jolly
Ranchers
this is a rooster on a stick and when
you ever you go to a movie theater or
you go to like a circus circuses are
very popular back home you always get
this it's so freakin good I just suck
his little head and die back no flavor
it is nobody knows it's just it's like a
pizza shop favorite look like it doesn't
have like a fruity flavor it just as
like sweet is it fun
it's a lot of fun I'm having a blast
Jolly Ranchers are amazing no problem
with this not having a stick is I'm
scared that if I stuck a little too hard
and my de truc like going oh my god
well Gary thank you for cheering your
sax thank you for reading my snacks guys
expand your snack world try Russian
snacks try dried fish don't try dried
fish do whatever you want
da svidaniya
[Music]
you